foreign
sequency thing and I hit the wrong
button oh I found it
[Music]
[Music]
stupid YouTube I never had to do it that
was cool sorry I like that intro that
was cool I got a I got a friend of the
channel that actually knows how to use
computers so he started to do some nice
little intros like that so it's very
cool and I love that T-shirt with I
played by Jeffrey Coombs Jeffrey Coombs
who plays all of the Star Trek
characters
it's true you don't realize this but
we're actually just Jeffrey comes
talking to each other right now yeah
every time I go out the door I assume
Jeffrey Combs is every person I speak to
and thank you anyway Sean ferric from
a track called how are you sir I'm very
good thank you very much for inviting me
I'm absolutely delighted to be here
thank you very much for saying yes
because you'll imagine you're quite busy
so I
I I actually hear that your YouTube
channel is doing reasonably well
recently I mean did you get monetized or
something recently I think it's uh yeah
yeah you know we got one or two clicks
up no I I really appreciate that thank
you very much uh yes yes it's done well
recently we've hit 250 000 subscribers
we love you all all of you
and me and you and that guy and Jeffrey
Cooper
um do you get a nice little plaque from
YouTube because you get one for every so
often don't you we get so we we had a
check so because we were all talking
about this on the channel so 100K a
million which we are very far away from
and 10 million
don't think we're gonna get that would
be lovely if we did don't get me wrong
but I don't think we're gonna get that
one you never know I'm just looking for
my first hundred thousand that'll do hey
If Ever I get an email off YouTube I'm
always excited but normally it's a we've
changed our policies again
but anyway
so I thought it was a little bit of an
icebreak before we talk about track and
I've got a few little things I wanted to
ask you about I've got notes and
everything this is how seriously I'm
taking this conversation uh sure so but
I thought I'd have a couple little
questions just to test your Trek
knowledge just to see if you really are
the Trek man or if you're just an
imposter yeah I'm nervous now
they're easy they're well the last one's
a bit of a sod
um okay so and I need a full answer for
this how many decks does the Enterprise
E have and a full answer
well okay so it depends on the film is
the answer to that so
um in first Contact it changes
because uh I think Picard identifies 24
decks but then the security officer who
I will say His Name Escapes me he says
that the Borg have taken decks 26
upwards
um then you get to Nemesis and they're
talking about deck 29 but deck 29 is the
top of this gaping Castle it's a tardis
yeah I was kind of like oh my God the
Viceroy has fallen to his death on the
bottom deck
yeah so the answer is whatever number
you think it is you're probably right
and the official answer
uh the official answer I think is 29. I
think it's 24. so you're not doing that
when we've actually seen images of the
internet somebody counted oh okay 24.
you can see it in the background
so somebody somebody literally gone one
two three something but I mean we don't
have
books on the e-doo or anything like that
so
that that that's all right I am I
appreciate the person who did that
um and could they take on the Enterprise
a next
uh
again depending on which movie
um or JJ Abrams when you just sort of go
[Laughter]
King JJ Abrams okay then well see life
on the Enterprise D obviously this is I
remember when this video came out it's
only meant to be do you know there's
dolphins on the Enterprise D yeah I read
like the book like 10 years ago but it
was amazing so
how many are on the Enterprise D how
many sea life creatures
sea life creatures I'm gonna be straight
but they have no idea
um so um
we'll do it you're doing very well
12.
there are 12 Dolphins so there's 12
dolphins and then two Takaya whales that
apparently the supervisors which I
always like that I love that I don't
think Dolphins can't be trusted you have
to have whale supervisors I love that I
think it's just yeah when when if we're
coming to a complete stop or something
I'll make sure they don't have too long
on their breaks or whatever but I don't
know
um this one I'm confident you'll know
why are they called Jeffrey tubes
because they are named after the
original designer of the USS Enterprise
Matt Jeffries
see I knew you'd know that one
I just love that there's like why are
they called Jeffrey
no incidentally was also played by
Jeffrey Combs oh well because he played
everything Cisco's played by different
Combs and so was Deanna Troy um
last question apparently as well there
isn't in Canon answer for why it's
called the Jeffrey tube as well but I
didn't know this but according to one of
the websites there was supposedly an
engineer in the 22nd century called WM
Jeffrey and that's the Canon answer
so
I think we can make this [ __ ] up
um okay full answer again though when
was the Enterprise D destroyed
so
there was 23.73 in orbit of Viridian
three
um
but
technically the sorcerer section wasn't
destroyed
no that was that was brought back
um and I believe turned into a museum
but don't quote me on that one he says
on a live video
um
but then also I suppose that would have
been the final writing place you have
cause and effect where it was destroyed
what five or six times in the episode
that's true I didn't get that I didn't
go that far
I've got the final battle in Generations
Generations which was yeah because that
was
was it 20 was it 2366
encounter farqua which would be 23.73
which is 2371 try to remember because I
tried to remember what year it was
launched because it was in service for
well Seven Seasons I'll give you a clue
that you you did just say the answer oh
23.73
23.71 23 71. okay gotta say that anyway
yeah 2371 in orbit of iridium three by a
class D12 bird of prey that was
susceptible to some sort of ionic pulse
are brilliant until they aren't they're
kind of like that kind of ship like
their Grace until you find like like the
Death Star
or the Excelsior class I was going to
say as well the Excelsior class
brilliant built so many of those damn
things but they blow up a lot more Yeah
the more you stop up the plumbing the
easier it is to oh no the more you
complicate the problem the easier it is
to stop up the drain exactly I've ever
seen that um I can't remember what it's
called it's that um 8-bit thing that
they did the there's the guy that
designed the Death Star and he's talking
to nobody tell me about space Wizards
how much pause it's a channel that does
loads these little they look like
Graphics from old N64 computer games oh
that's kind of annoying me but anyway
um I love that right so I thought we
were getting to actually talk about Star
Trek as it is in the moment
and this is a target channel so I might
wander and just I'll get a little bit
towards the end if you don't mind
because I think there are parallels
between like the two franchises and
obviously hopefully we're going to be
getting started going back at some point
soon so it'll be interesting to wonder
if we can learn some of the lessons from
Star Trek or if the new creators can but
anyway first of all Picard season three
is coming to our screens shortly
generally speaking what was your
feelings on oh this is a loaded question
I know but Picard season one or two what
what we've had so far so Seas so season
one
um and I'm gonna be very honest in how I
ask this right so season one had a
tremendously good opening episode I
thought remembrance is one of the better
Pilots uh of Star Trek now it's
obviously aided by the fact that you
know some of these characters already
um but I thought I thought the one the
the biggest R about remembrance is that
they'd revealed the cube in the trader
because I thought that is an amazing
reveal of a ship
um
trailers so I think I always do that
right always I think they're better at
it nowadays I think Marvel have sort of
led the way they they try two trailers
that trick you that make you think
they're going one way then they really
go the other
but um but yeah I'm with you on that
um as the season went on I thought I
thought it became quite uneven you have
characters that I wanted to see more of
that we didn't get more of and
characters that perhaps are a bit too
much of that I thought you know you're
overdoing it because you're overdoing it
I'm getting a bit frustrated with X
character
um then we get to Nepenthe which I
thought was just a beautiful episode
um I thought Marina serious has never
been better as Deanna Troy yeah I
thought I thought just like Jonathan
Francis everyone's dad you know is and
actually I really liked kestra
um I thought she was really good I've
actually I've I've watched that uh Lulu
Wilson I believe I've seen her in
several projects uh particularly in some
of Mike Flanagan stuff and actually she
is a very good actress so I thought okay
brilliant enjoying it enjoying it
enjoying it
um I don't I'm not going to go into the
copy and paste Fleet it's been talked
about to death uh and it's been ready
moves the details and loves the ships
and loves things like this that was the
biggest irritation to me it was it was
and look to me
I want to because I am not in any way
I'm not a designer I don't build CGI
assets so I sometimes I go look it's a
bit Rich for me to be like oh God that
was a bit like who was a bit lazy wasn't
it I know there are there are issues
available and I don't know it was
disappointing to see on screen uh it was
frustrating and also separate of the
fact that they were all the inquiry
class and then it was you had pretty
much I think three different Romulan
ships
um when you have
giant army versus giant army there's no
Stakes you know so that was for me so
that's what frustrated me about season
one it was very uneven liked a lot of
stuff liked a lot of stuff with Brent
Spiner
um I I thought uh Patrick Stewart uh I
thought you see it was a different take
on Picard so it took me a little while
to kind of get used to that
um and that's just it's been 20 years
you know took takes takes a few minutes
from an accident point of view he's an
old man so yeah
great exactly yeah so let me go into
season two straight away that that the
Stargazer brilliant uh
phenomenal I I did a video going Star
Trek is back getting in this is
brilliant best track we've had in years
absolutely I mean what and it and it
dressed so many things straight away we
got loads of starfleets because I know
that had been a criticism of season one
it was just like
so we get that right front to the center
in episode one and of course then we get
the amazing Fleet you get the Luna class
debuting in live action you get of
course obviously the Stargazer itself
you get the return of the Sovereign
class and you get those beautiful Star
Trek Online chips and I am over the moon
at this stage I'm just like this is
amazing I love the new uniforms
um and and it was just everything about
it and then I thought the return of Q
was so good in episode one I love that
they made a bit of just a bit of a gag
about like we'll have a two second thing
all right here's young Cube brilliant
love it
um I there's been a lot of criticism
toward Whoopi Goldberg and that I've
said I thought I only watched it the
other day again I I really enjoyed the
scene the one thing and I've said this
before the only thing I would have just
left out was don't address the fact that
she's older I I thought that was
unnecessary I mean I get it she looks
older but yeah okay yes elore
institute's age fine whatever that's it
as the city my only frustration about
was that virtually everything we'd seen
with Whoopi Goldberg in in the actual
episode we'd already seen it in the
clips there was nothing there was
virtually nothing new and so by the end
of it you're thinking well I already
knew that that was that's another case
that was my only frustration
yeah that and that was it yeah it was
this other case of you know kind of a
get you on it you know you're excited
let's put it in the trade and get the
radio as well brilliant but then as you
say it's like oh oh we've actually seen
the scene nearly
um
then as the season went on
um it did now I know it there was look
there was extra things there was
pandemics happening and you can see
that's not Cheryl's fault but yeah look
you could see the like you know hey
we're in L.A and both of those people
are in La as well you know
that's an exaggeration but
um
the
reals the storyline dragged
which is which is a shame so that by the
time we get to the finale in Rio selects
to stay behind
um I mean yes I assumed he was going to
but I got there in episode four
yeah you got there quite early on didn't
you yeah he was my favorite character as
well out of the new characters I love
Rios
um I just love the actor I've loved him
and everything he's done he's brilliant
he's brilliant now I'll be honest I I
met him in season one sorry as in
um
my first encounter with him was in
season one of the card I've subsequently
gone back and watched him a lot of stuff
I'm like hey so good
um
there was there was a there was a
feeling of a little bit of floundering
in the middle of the season
um we've gone back a Time cool okay and
Scrambler doing time travel that's fine
so we've got back there
and then there is
unfortunately there is the feeling of
not enough story to fill the episode
quota
um and so you have a little bit of dry
dough one of the things I I would pay
money to watch James Carlos read the
phone book so that's you know loved
seeing him there
um I got a big massive kick out of
um the refit nx01 finally showing up on
screen as a toy in young Picard's house
I thought that was brilliant yeah
Enterprise with the drive section and
everything yeah so that was great and
then and I I really like the finale I
think it's a great last episode
um I and you know what I've I have seen
I have seen and I'm not gonna say anyone
is particularly right or wrong people
really like seeing Will Wheaton black
people really didn't like seeing will we
I didn't I didn't mind well weaken
coming back actually I thought that was
a nice little nod and I think a lot of
Geeks we hated will we and we hated
Crusher when he was a kid
um I remember I went to like a
trackathon years ago they watched all
the Star Treks back to baptism
uh Nemesis no it's not nemesis
um first Contact had just come out so we
sort of like but we weren't allowed to
watch it till like six o'clock in the
morning because we're not aired in
America sort of thing so we watched all
the Star Treks and six of them we got to
watch that and I remember at one point
somebody stood up because they didn't do
little questions between the films and
they go who's the most hated character
and everybody went whoa but then that
point yeah yeah
um but but then then he was in like Big
Bang Theory and he's done things like
that and everyone's kind of like I saw a
t-shirt that was because um was it um
hate hate Wesley love
um I forgot his name now will anyway
yeah well yeah and I'm like yeah we love
will we we just can't stand Wesley I was
only recently for for one of the
vloggers we went back and did a re-watch
of all of next gen and so
Nostalgia helps Wesley particularly
Season Two Season Two hmm if you if you
can separate season two from season one
which is difficult don't get me wrong
but if you can separate season one and
Season Two Season Two Wesley he's grown
up a bit he's he has got better and the
writing has got better uh season one
much like many season ones of any shows
they didn't know kind of who the
character was he was a kid
um and and it shows in season one it
really does and it you know rod and
Brees think of oh we'll have Wesley save
the ship every week that was bashing you
over the head
um and the balance wasn't there in
season two they they stripped that back
a little bit which seriously served the
character
um and then kind of going into season
three he got a bit better and then he
was gone obviously then in season four
um someone has some people have made the
point that the Cameo we got was Will
Wheaton as opposed to Wesley and I have
to say I see I see their point
um
but but then again but then I I asked
myself like well it's been 30 years
you know what does what does Wesley
Crusher speak and act like today you
know I mean well it's 30 years
what he was doing he was time jumping
and as the whatever he is we don't know
what it would be now
um but yeah I I have to admit I think
that whole scene
didn't need to be there it was just a
nod
and to make the fans go I do think a lot
with new track they keep they've changed
Canon and things and a lot of things
have different but they do keep giving
us little knowledge they give the
trekkies little nods and I think that
was just one of those things that was
just this is for you guys you know just
like
his will we'd love to see I'm not sure
if it will happen but we'd love to see
like not a spin-off series just centered
on Wil Wheaton and uh Corey but
they can rock up in Discovery time is
meaning do you know what I mean like you
can link these shows together through
characters like this
um and you know it doesn't necessarily
need to affect one thing one way or they
could Rock up strange new worlds do you
know what I mean uh it's all the future
for Corey so she's she's laughing but um
yeah I which is one thing I I like when
you have a kind of a connected franchise
like this where you can do little things
like that I mean lower decks and just
pencil them in you know kind of Will on
your way to the bathroom record this
line thanks very much cool you know
there's still rumors about a live-action
lower decks and I'm like
the crossover is happening uh it's
happening in season two of strange new
world
yeah that's gonna be
I'm worried about that we'll talk about
that in a bit we'll finish talking about
Picard and then we'll go back so excited
I do I do want to talk about the
animated stuff
um but right so the game the Picard
series three now oh they're picardo
series two my main problem was and I've
actually argued with Terry metallis
about this on on um Twitter a little bit
and it might have even got a little bit
unpleasant
but anyway I I just have to say like I'm
not necessarily saying this to you but
to everyone and
whatever you think of the show no one
has any right to give the show makers or
the actors grief for it if you don't
know that's fine and again I'm not
suggesting you do this but that's just
the point out there because you see some
people uh I'm not going to name names
but I've seen some people basically at
Terry matalis you are this you are that
you have ruined everything grow
the crappy got over the Titan yeah
remember I'm not a massive fan of the
design of the Titan but don't tweet the
the show or anybody else that they've
that it's a pile of crap and they really
had a go at him now I always just got a
bit we just disagreed but um my pick was
basically how do you take a series and
ruin literally the best villain in in
sci-fi and that's what I felt by the end
of the book you're just thinking like
well so so what's up and I know there
may be an offshoot and I know there and
we don't really know what the rest of
the Borg situation is following Janeway
and Voyager
um
because I know they they took down the
uni Matrix black was only like one of
five and we don't know if it's spread
amongst so no there's lots of things we
don't know about the Borg but but it did
get to the end of that the second series
season you like
they've neutered the Borg how do you
manage that
it's like I would argue Voyager did that
long before Picard ever came along
um end game I love I think endgame is a
terrific uh finale for a voice best
finale out of all of those Seasons to be
honest
it was better than the end of
um yeah of Next Generation it was better
than the DS9 finale the DS9 finale that
was like three episodes before the
finale that was awesome and then it sort
of they had all these other Loose Ends
to type and then they sort of did that
the Voyager yeah the voice just series
finale finale for me was it was just so
satisfying there wasn't it it was
actually so good yeah and actually Kate
more grew I don't think gets nearly
enough praise for playing both captain
and Admiral Janeway and that she's
brilliant at it and obviously the return
of Alice I love Susanna Thompson but the
return of Alice Krieg at the board when
we were all introduced to you know so so
cool my issue with voyager is that after
scorpion which is I mean that that's a
brilliant fantastic idea and dark
Frontier is very good but like after
scorpion you're like you know oh my God
it's the board that'd be fun
I think that was it so someone made the
point before that once the episode
started with voyager hunting the Borg
that's when you know it's like that's
when they went down now yeah
um so that was so that was so going into
Picard that was my feeling
um actually didn't mind the Borg so much
in season works of barely in it
um in season one going into season two
um I just I've just in you know I'm
taking the show series of Bible it's it
is a mini a bit like sevens mini
collective in survival Instinct is it a
it is its own separate entity
um and plus I just love the nickname
borgati yeah I just love that you know
kind of like
um and but yeah I think because I loved
Annie worshing I thought she was really
good she was very very different to take
on the queen
um and I think it worked in the context
of the show it'd be interesting now to
see
Annie Alice and Susanna in a room
together that would be that would be
very interesting to see those three
queens in in a situation together
um
so well I didn't think they just they
did you just you know sometimes when
they've really put the effort in and
then I mean they are similar enough but
they're obviously fine actually and
they're different I I love the the
balance you get with that
um and yeah I just might like say my
problem is that I don't know why where
we are with the but there was such the
best friend I've always said we'll talk
about what we want after Picard in a
minute if that's right but I'd love the
book they're just the best deal in there
you know you've got the villains in
sci-fi is like the Borg
the Daleks that you know you like things
like this they're the the epitome
they're just awesome the Shadows from
Babylon five I think with are a similar
sort of thing they're just such good
villains and they've ruined them
um but like yeah I can see what you're
quite saying about a voyager but I think
by the end of Voyager they were still
pretty scary
and they changed them during Voyager to
sort of match up to what they made the
alterations they made for the movie
didn't they so they they did sort of
change and evolve a little bit but not
too much not like what they do with the
Klingons
but we'll we'll move away from changing
Abrams
um it's funny because I think I'm
thinking well I don't I don't think I'm
alone but I love I mean it's first
contact the board was scary yeah that's
that's the best track film for me
um the new ones hopefully yeah yeah
totally totally understand I mean it's
incredible I mean I vividly remember
being watching a cinema being like we're
all gonna die aren't we
but I actually really liked the design
of the Borg in the Next Generation
because they look so they have just had
tubes thrown into them and they have
just been you know kind of so but then I
I definitely I I do I I very much
appreciate the looking like like you
know we're gonna go with what we did
next gen but also horror movie and I
think it really worked and we are going
to make them genuinely scary as well I
remember watching first Contact though
and obviously we haven't seen the
Enterprise
um e at that point and it was obviously
pre-internet so they we hadn't had all
the all the YouTube videos and all the
link we've sort of nothing so none of us
it's in it
um and you can always see it was a tiny
little thing on the poster you couldn't
really see it so I mean I'm British as
as are you you know how emotionally
we are so to be in a cinema Irish but
right yeah yeah you guys are a little
less emotionally spotted than us but
English are more like oh I'm just
terribly sorry
um but you know it's like when it came
on and then I'm starting a cinema full
of like 200 people and everybody went
she's like Jesus that was that was an
emotional response
gorgeous reveal in the film
um
um but like but I I suppose on the point
I'm not I'm not necessarily disagreeing
with you
um I I just like it's it's girati's
little Collective
um that one thing I wasn't crazy about
was as the queen is sort of assimilating
girati um and she's eating the car
battery and she kills a guy and it's
been hours earlier but she's actually
only around the corner that kind of
stuff I was bit like this is and it kind
of goes back into the your pattern for
time yeah that was kind of go back into
that the actual I should quite like the
ship
oh that was a bit like you're kind of
like Oh I like that one that's that's a
new one
um but um it's in a lot of the memes
about it though I've seen one or two
yeah
space vagina excellent
what was it someone's got it the borgosy
yeah
which is yeah which I think I've got a
point about
that my whole problem with Picard season
two I think this is the if when zarati
had come through the thing I mean for me
it was quite clear where it was going
from about episode three you could I
felt like you could tell it was
individuality but if she'd have gone
through and opened up hailing
frequencies and gone Picard it's me I
can't explain but I'm bored now we've
got to save the universe and then can we
have it can we have a two-minute
conversation and then we'll we'll go and
save the universe
but they didn't she attacked tried to
take over the thing and then Q got to
step in and all that the whole season
actually doesn't really make sense and
if you could have just gone it's me
give me two minutes
and and that like in in that respect
you're not you're not wrong like you
know kind of when when something
can be handled with a conversation
like
I can enjoy what I'm watching but yeah
you know
like okay yeah we have to get drones to
go back in time cool okay Agnes hiya
we'll have a chat with this after we we
deal with this and don't worry you are
going to decide to go back because I
exist
um and uh yeah so that depends on how
which sort of time theory time you want
me through you go by my my other issue
what does q actually do in that series
smack the card
yeah
none of what actually happens makes any
difference because Germany comes through
as the ball Queen and comes through in
the you know I think at the beginning of
this year before
Q does anything
so it doesn't actually do anything
I don't think experts I suppose um
Picard does blow up the ships doesn't he
self-destructs them
in the original bit which then changes
yeah so um so so if we go linear you're
dead right so uh
then unknown board Queen arrives on the
ship
Picard self-destructs the ship boom Q
steps in now Q is non-linear so let's
yeah we'll put a pin in that one right
and then confusing Let's ignore it yeah
does the problem when you go into time
travel it's like oh okay good luck
um and then so if Q's entire
mission was we need to help Picard
overcome this childhood trauma
that will then allow him to try
um
there's shades of what they did in
tapestry but in tapestry they did it in
one episode
there's probably there's probably a
super code of scenes where you would
have season two where you get Picard and
Q and I think I like this it's a bit
like uh to quite Lord of the Rings it's
butter spritched over too much bread
um and then you and then you get to that
last scene which is a beautiful scene
because it's John Delancey and Patrick
Stewart saying
like so I'm not a crier but even I was
like
okay
but he's just it's just such a like a
boxer John Lansing it's a dorm and
everything and um
although if that is the last time let's
say Q died in that scene right Q ceases
to existence so again Q is not linear so
you know the bit where he goes um let me
catch up
uh we were joking on the channel going
like all of his experiences in Voyager
happened in that finger click yeah you
know so that's why you see him get a
little bit older throughout you know the
years on Voyager everything and that
relationship and we're gonna have this
big massive good boy with Captain Jane
or a voice Admiral Janeway as well you
know that's gonna be fine because he's
not linear and he can just come back to
Picard
you know yeah the time is irrelevant
song yeah exactly yeah because I'd love
I would love love to see John Delancey
and Kate Mulgrew just interacted again
because they have such good chemistry
together I mean they've known each other
decades which I didn't know when I was
watching things like death wish q and
the gray I thought like you know because
because I mean and this is Q did not
work in Deep Space Nine
you know Picard quoted Shakespeare at Q
uh couldn't get rid of him on a bet
um Cisco punched Q never bothered him
again yep
try to have kids with him
um but but yeah so my general things for
Picard was that I think they both
seasons started great
and then
I'm disappointed the end of season one
where the things come out of the the bad
guy and I was like I just like it's just
crap and obviously 200 Picard into an
Android and blah blah blah all these
bits I I wasn't a fan of
um but they've just but my my fear for
season three is obviously these are
characters I love TNG was my first love
I was
12 or 13 or something like that when it
came out
um you know by the end of it that was
why that was my like education in sci-fi
you know that was me
every Thursday on a you know it was on
Sky one and I'd be like you know because
I couldn't wait for it so these These
are the characters I just adore and I
just think the first two seasons just
let
the character of Picard down just
quite badly and um and I don't like the
way they've took the Federation either I
don't like the whole how they tried to
sort of like shoe horn the Romulan
um Supernova in from the JJ Abrams
um to sort of like have this cross I
just didn't didn't a lot of it sort of
confused me or disappointed me I think
but then season three we start getting
the adverts for that and you're looking
I'm looking at again going are they
going to do this to me again
I'm so excited about season three
I'm loving what I'm seeing but just just
from the little bits we have seen what
are your
initial thoughts oh I'm pumped I am
pumped
um I think
like even like those last couple of
trailers where we see them interacting
with each other you see them playing
characters again it's just like and it
feels like they've stepped off the set
of Nemesis
um which has possibly made some people's
eyes twitch but uh like I love this the
the dry humor of Michael Doran you know
I now love a pacifist Lifestyles again
that is one of my biggest
disappointments from the last 10 years
really we've never got a wolf spin-off
he's definitely he definitely apparently
he's been arguing for for decades and it
would have been brilliant because he's
brilliant and Michael Dawn again
everything he's ever in that's adorable
but um
you know he says oh by the way now I'm a
pacifist and they beat him out does he
know he's got a sword attached to his
back when he says that just it's like
the whole thing I choose a peaceful life
doesn't mean I can't fight I just choose
a piece well we've seen amusing The
Sword in the trailer
the new the new design
um it's uh I'm I I have to say I'm
excited again I mean
need we even squee over the Enterprise f
well I did say that
um again telling my last had to come out
and say the Enterprise E is not in
um the series
well we know it's not because we see the
Enterprise
I don't know why people have to ask but
I do love that they've gone with the F
and again they've used the Star Trek
Online design I love the whole history
of where that design came from and
everything and it's a it is a gorgeous
looking shoe so there's nothing at the
park again apparently it's not going to
be in it very much but the yeah I I I'd
say we'll either get us probably will
either get it in the pilot or the last
episode it'll be it'll be something like
that because if you look at as it flies
by it looks like there's a celebration I
think it's the christening
the or um in in the Shameless book in
our trailer breakdown for the uh there
is a there's a poster on the wall
behind Pickard in that opening shot and
it says first Contact Day yes so so yeah
um which which would make sense and
obviously the flagship
being at Earth and everything would
completely make sense
um they did say that it's important to
the story I think Tim was a couple of
days ago said he supports the story but
he's not in it much so don't think this
is going to be the Voyages of the
Starship Enterprise again which we know
because we've seen the Titan it's yeah
and I think and on various policies that
like you know so our hero ship of season
three is the Titan that's you know which
is I mean I'm I'm actually because I
obviously the first time I saw the Titan
I was a bit like
okay when I saw it dead on right I
wasn't I wasn't mad shuffed about the
deflector design that's kind of it's
like the Excelsior but it's not it's
like the Constitution class but it's not
about okay correct so I went away and
then the next trailer came out and you
see it from the dorsal View and I went
right okay I'm much more on board now
now that I've seen more of the ship and
of course the amazing Bill Krause who
has been sharing beautiful images on
Twitter
um so he is uh uh a fan model maker
who's been commissioned along the way to
build these beautiful uh practical
models has given us like well there you
go there's the type name there's that
and that that that's like yeah okay now
I like it now
I I I'm still that silly person that
like you know there's probably ships
I've seen along the way Voyager where
maybe initially I didn't love them I
came to love them and now I love Voyager
uh but I didn't like the designs when it
first came out
I thought it looked weird
and then now it's probably my favorite
ship if I look back at it oh no
the the E's my favorite ship but it's
probably one of my favorite ships I love
the Akira classes on but yes and it's
one of my favorite shoes because you
just like go for for what it is for it's
a warship that makes way more sense than
all the other Starships we see but um I
didn't like the fact I don't like the
nose of the definite I thought it looked
weird when it first came when it first
appeared so I think I just thought it
looked yeah because because we're so
used to seeing the swept back in the
cells or or even if you look at say like
the kind of the outliers like the
constellation class they're still
separate from the drive section uh or I
should have got the Miranda Class
probably easier example and then you get
this this this this little pancake comes
in you're like what is that gonna and
also re-watching the search there
recently portal defiant she gets paid in
the first time that's what she said
you're kind of like that's a hell of an
introduction then you get things like
way of the warrior and you're like sure
actually I think she's gonna be fine I
think she'll do that okay yeah oh no
from like a design and to also the shift
has to fit the series doesn't it so for
the purpose of the series it fit
perfectly but for me we mentioned
earlier that like the first episode of
most sci-fi first series star of most
sacrifice and TNG the first season
wasn't great for me it turned a corner
when they killed Anna Troy it was a
character I loved but it made more sense
when they re-jigged it you know I mean
War for security made more sense
I think they rejigged it they went okay
and then it got a loads better Voyager I
thought was born until seven of nine
came in and you would not be alone for
sure
um and Deep Space Nine to be honest
wasn't great until Cisco shaved his head
um and then it improved I remember I
remember on actually I remember on First
Watch even feeling the same way
um and I think again Nostalgia helps so
going back and watching season one of
DS9 was in my opinion up until uh recent
Seasons probably the strongest first
season of the Star Trek and I have to
say I have a lot of love for the first
season of the original series because
the original series came out this is
what we are
um and there's a lot of great like
sitting in the edge is season one and
things like that
um whereas in uh like season one of DS9
you've got Emissary which I would argue
is still probably the best pilot of any
of the series
um started with a bang didn't it that
was fantastic the first five minutes of
that episode right right
um and then it has things like duet
which is one of the all-time great
episodes of Star Trek uh in the hands of
the prophets which is an incredible
season finale it gives us Kai win you
know uh or well Vedic win at the time
but then you have other episodes
throughout season of dotted around and
yes overall the season isn't as strong
as DS9 would go on to become
um
and uh listen I'll make the argument for
move along home ala Moraine is a catchy
song
[Laughter]
so for the new track oh sorry when
Picard ends then there's quite a few
rumors about what sort of series we
might see there's a lot of there's loads
of rumors about whether kurtzman's going
to be allowed to continue with Star Trek
and stuff I keep hearing because it
paramounts Financial issues but let's
just assume it moved forwards as we
expect and we don't get any massive
surprises
then in theory when Picard ends another
series should be commissioned in theory
um what what sort of thing would you
like to see I want to stay in this time
period
um so we have Discovery off in the far
future which I'm sure we'll discuss that
in a minute but and we've got strange
new worlds back in the past so I want to
stay post Nemesis we have Prodigy and
lower Decks that are in that 2380s so I
would like to continue into the 25th
Century now whether that is people have
spoken about a seven Rafi spin-off
whether it's whether they do it that way
for all we know this is going to be a
backdoor pilot to the next next
Generation I don't think it will be but
you know there's there's things like
that that but that's the period I want
to stay in and
um but it took it it's funny to address
the you know people talk about you know
paramounts Finance encouragement Alice
curtisman has been fired and rehired
three times since we started this live
chat here oh yes
several tweets just while we miss out
there we go yeah yeah and people don't
understand that he can't actually be
fired that's not quite how this Works he
it's the production company but we won't
get into that anyway but if I actually
put a video not long ago and Kurt's been
sacked is the title I'm going I know
because that'll get reaction but then in
the video I explained how it's actually
not true and that's not how this works
but they may just take Star Trek away
from him give him other projects and do
something else with is it Smokehouse
Productions I forget
um but no Smokehouse is um you should I
should know the answer to this uh it's
something like that but it's not smokers
because Smokehouse is owned by
the other actor who's very pretty and I
forgot his [ __ ] nut but anyway it
doesn't matter the secret hideout secret
hijack thank you
um so secret ID I've got a deal with
Paramount exclusive deal for the next
five years so at least three years so
but apparently the deal from April
doesn't necessarily say Star Trek
whereas the previous deal did
apparently whether that's true or not in
the case I would I would need to see
receipts
I actually start the video with I'm not
sure this is true but but
um the one thing I would say though is
that we don't actually know after
and after discovery season five after
strange new worlds we don't actually
have anything official beyond that as
far as I know I think even Prodigy isn't
official after the second season Prodigy
is yeah so Prodigy definitely confirmed
for his 20 episode season two we've got
lower decks season four confirmed
um Picard obviously is ending after
season three I think
I I would have to dig out sources I
Rumblings of season six of Discovery
haven't I but I would have to dig out my
sources yeah yeah but there's as many I
mean that gets canceled every Coachman
Coachman gets sacked and disco gets
canceled it's like one of those
revolving doors oh yeah 100
um but what so yeah I I just want to see
normal track I actually generally
believe strange new world is so popular
because it's like
it's basically like TNG it's like the
original series I mean
um after that we've not seen just a
series based on a Starship go and
explore and stuff
and we've not seen that you know
um DS9 wasn't that Voyage it wasn't
really that because it was still and it
was a ship exploring but it was with a
there was a you know a reason for it
something so I think that's why strange
new walls is as to be honest as popular
as this
because it is just and that's what I'd
love to see I want to say the Titan or
something else just
explore I would I would I would love
that as well I think yeah I've
definitely I've made no secret to fight
like the episodic nature of strange in
the worlds seriously has benefited us
I'm really excited for season two and
also like I would have been one of the
people uh back around DS9 Voyager time
right I'm like give us more serialized
storytelling I love these multi episode
stories it was great and I'm not I've
it's not that I've ate my words it's
just TV moved to that and that's fine
you know obviously look look Game of
Thrones for so long did it so so well
The Sopranos the wire these like you
know these multi-season longings
obviously Enterprise season three is one
story all the way through with Aussie
highlights along the way and then
I and then and then you get the the
issue when you have right well we have
to do a 10 episode season great okay so
let's get 10 episodes of story yeah
we'll do five
yeah
yes but but you know there's 10 episodes
yeah so yeah so that's right so that's
why but in strange new worlds they had
10 stories
yeah and I thought it was brilliant and
there's still the overarching this you
know podcasts that come to terms with
living in the chair you know you've got
all you've got all this going on and I
thought they absolutely smash it I would
definitely I agree with you I would love
to see whatever the next show ends up
being I mean let's be honest there will
be a next show
um yeah whatever it is being I I would
like him let's stick with the episodic
yeah I think so
um I think the only reason that there
might be little issues if Paramount plus
hasn't been as successful as they hoped
but then um
I think they would just go back to doing
what they did just two years ago and
companies like Amazon would you know
it's like because in America it was on
Paramount plus but over here it was on
Prime you know and they get a bit of
money that way and I think that's just
they'll just return to that if Paramount
plus is a problem and I can't see them
getting rid of kurtzman because at the
end of the day through that production
company they've got contracts and at the
end of the day it has been successful
um even with discovery which we'll talk
about that so I I I assume you're a fan
of Discovery then
I am a fan of Discovery uh I'm not
saying it's been an easy path
yeah there has been times where I think
it would be easier to say you know kind
of like
I don't know yeah I was a fan of Nemesis
then to say I was a Founder but um
I I struggled with season one and not
just the Aesthetics um there's you know
I I get why the Aesthetics are the way
that they are
um and that's that's that's fine I have
no issue with that and I'm sure we'll
talk about the Klingons in a second but
um it was more so the tone
I struggled with because and and the
pace the tone and the pacing of season
one I re because I thought
oh yeah we can do dark DS9 but I don't
know these characters
you know I don't really know what you
know by the end of season one sure yep
cool Burnham and saru okay I was like
right there there's they've been more or
less the constants all the way through
um then Tilly uh season one
Lorca as it turns out didn't really
matter
um and uh Giorgio
that was my favorite character Giorgio
and I am very happy for you so anyway
um Michelle yo I love myself I love
Michelle I love Michelle
doing a section 31 wasn't there and I'm
like I'll be on board with that for the
longest time that was uh it's Signed
Sealed Delivered in the can and then I
think it's just her star blew up you
know what I mean like she is now I mean
they're talking I'm sure there will be
an Oscar not too long in the future
um and she deserves it I mean everything
everywhere all at once was one of the
best films of recent years
um it was a surprise movie for me I
couldn't believe it
um and I actually I I quite enjoyed
Xiang Chi but there's no question she's
the best thing in it
so that I think if the original section
31 plan might need a bit of a rejig
um you know just because when would she
have the time it still seems to be lean
in that noise like towards the end of
lower decks we see the section 31 again
and like and they do they have been
really good at the animated of like
weave in
them into their live action give us a
little hint so I'm wondering maybe
they're still going that way because
that seems to be or maybe they'll take
the ideas they have for that and just
move into look I don't know but it's
it's but it's quite like at the moment
because there isn't a pilot the world's
their oyster you know I mean they can do
anything they want with the witches
which is great so I mean the the say
like you know the same with any writer
will think the same way as like you know
it's your first project take your time
don't just rush out a pilot take your
time you know
um don't encounter at Far Point this
um but yeah so I'll see someone like uh
going back and watching it
it get it it gets an awful a bit I I do
like I do like the opening two episodes
um I think they work well as a movie
yeah I think it's a good film it was um
for me the the problem with disco is the
technology with the whole Spore Drive I
don't like
um I thought it was lazy it makes
absolutely no sense
um and I never got it
um that a whole episode when you've got
the um when they're aboard the sister
ship and they can't figure out why
everyone's dead and then um it's the
which is actually a real thing as well
I'm talking about maybe but and then
they kind of defeat that really easily
even though it defeated the entire
um crew any other one I thought no okay
but the Spore Drive is my main issue
with the show
I like it now
at all I have to I have to say I was a
bit like this is you know they've made a
big deal about this is this is Canon
this is the past and as I say I can
you know Aesthetics aside it's being
made in the 20 teens I get it but this
is the best piece of this is not an
original joke by any means but this is
the best technology ever so let's not
tell Captain Janeway yeah let's not tell
anybody and then they kind of explain
that at the end of season two and I'm
even that I'm sort of a bit like that is
so [ __ ] lazy
you're breaking like the secret weapons
like you know oh no Voyager 75 000 years
away well if everyone just promises not
to say anything we'll bring you home
tomorrow we'll remove it from all of the
records that's nice I did like the refit
going into in the future I like I like
that they did that refit
um and I I hated the design again I know
where the history of it came from and
why it was why it's that shape I hated
the design of the Disco but it grew on
me it did grow on me I usually initially
I did struggle with it as well
um and and similar it grew on me
um I do like I legitimately like it now
but I'm not gonna lie it took probably
until a good bit into season two I think
possibly seeing it alongside the
Enterprise helped
um yeah I love
that redesign of the Enterprise I
absolutely and my favorite Enterprise of
them all is the movie refit of of the
Original Series
yeah and I love the Disco prize
again because I think they they did a
really nice job without making it look
like it was like it fit sort of in the
time frame that it could that it would
evolve into the ship that we would love
eventually but it wasn't quite but you
know I think the designer so something a
little bit controversial about strange
new worlds and I think it is fantastic
I'm going to staff that but I actually
think if you break down the stories
it's not actually that good
but I think the characters are so
brilliant they've done such a good job
with that ensemble cast which I think
they which I think is the problem with
discovery
um the characters are forgettable I do I
have to say that has been one of my
issues with Discovery is that you'll
tease us with a great character but then
you won't give us something more you
know what I mean like like I want to
know I want to know about all about
Detmer I want to know more about a while
second I want to know more about Rhys
Bryce you know like because when you get
them I mean the performances are great
oh yeah they're not great actors great
actors actually no problem it's they
just give us an episode where Detmer has
to go off and she's been stuck on a
shuttle she's got to figure it out
um and then we not only as an audience
we get what it will hopefully be a good
episode but then we get to invest more
in these characters I know we've got an
awful lot more of Kolber as time has
gone on and kind of through Cobra we've
got more stamets as time has gone on
which again I think great
but you have a whole cast here
like I think we got more of Admiral
Vance in season three then we gotta have
the bridge crew
and that to me
I love that they're there but it's like
ah you've got the bridge crew there give
us some more you've got the characters
in discoveries this game that I could
say I've forgotten their name this is
I've I actually have stopped watching
this guy I didn't watch last series I
will get to it at some point I feel
ashamed that I haven't watched it
um but to be honest I need to subscribe
to Paramount plus to watch I will at
some point but the lady with the um
she's the I think she's the navigation
officer with the I cannot tell you her
name I can't tell you anything about her
um I I because I just don't I just don't
care and that's that's awful to say but
but in strange new worlds they've just
got these brilliant I mean it is led by
Pike an Anson Mount who's just
phenomenal he's funny and he's
um but you care but so even though I'm
watching some of the stories and I'm
thinking
no I'm not really bothered about the
store I couldn't I couldn't really tell
you what happened a lot of the episodes
I can tell you a lot of the
character-driven bits that happened sort
of thing and the character arcs and
because that had much more of an impact
on me
um and I I think it's the best track
they've done it's the best live action
track so far I think it's I think it's
beyond I absolutely adore it
um I can't wait for season two even
though I'm terrified about season two
because I the main reason why I hate
prequels is they tend to at some point
piss on Canon
how important is Canon do you think as a
full-blown Trekkie how how is there a
line
I
think they're relying I subscribe to the
Leonard Nimoy approach to college
when we when we box ourselves in
and we get too hung up on on Canon now
I'm not saying you know it doesn't
matter because I do I love connections I
love tracing history all the way through
but when it becomes this big like oh you
can't you cannot do that because you
know
um Jim Kirk was uh the you know serving
aboard the Republic on this year uh this
day and and okay
but like like for example don't kill
Spock you know Spock's gonna be fine
it's got plot armor that's right so I I
would say the challenge then to a writer
is how do you put him in Peril when you
know he's gonna be fine which I think
they did a really really good way of
doing it in the finale of stranger World
second again you know Spock's gonna be
okay so it's how does the story still
make you care about the Peril I like
that
um I so all these conversations come up
at Enterprise and I remember uh myself
and my mates at the time we were talking
about going like you know kind of but
first episode one they they swung and
they went
that Klingon doesn't look right not for
this time period And I remember being
quite annoyed when that Klingon ran out
um tiny Ron uh no not tiny Ron excuse me
I've got that one wrong Tony Ron is
Grand nigga's X
um May her do
um
uh Tony Tony Lister Tony Tiny Lister
sorry play that Klingon to that episode
and um I remember kind of gone like
those are some Fierce head ridges for an
original series Klingon you know what I
mean and then as time goes on I think
Enterprise is a good example and again
because I think it's aged so well
of
let's all take a second when we see
something that perhaps you know breaks
Cannon let's maybe take a second let's
maybe think that maybe this has been
thought through and I have been that
person going
well hold on there now for a second and
I tell you why you and your entire line
of ancestors are a terrible person for
making this decision
um like for example when Enterprise
regeneration I remember the first time
that aired and I was like I'm no you
know starfit never met the Borg now it's
one of my favorite episodes because if
you go back and watch it it's really
clever how they don't I think it's the
I've always said that I Enterprise was
my least favorite series of the of The
Originals I still actually really
enjoyed it but
um but regenerations was my favorite
episode and I think it might even be my
favorite top five Star Trek episodes
I'm really glad to hear that because
sometimes I will say how good an episode
is and people will be because I think
and I'm not I'm not trying to everyone
has the absolute flipping right to
believe whatever they want if they if
they're like nope listen there are five
series of Star Trek right and even
Enterprise we're not sure I'll be like
you know 100 the 60 animated series but
anyway
um
that's fine that's fine
it's when you're trying to give it give
it a chance have another look I think
regeneration is a really really really
clever thing of it but it it becomes a
prequel to cue whom while being a sequel
to First Contact and I think they they
walk it's a fine line and there's some
better I'm just like
so that flocks just not tell anyone that
he did yeah that's you know
at the time so don't they they have they
have poor memories at times they forget
things so it's like don't worry about it
um but yeah I I I'm a bit fuzzy when it
comes to Canon there are certain things
I think there is a I do think there is a
line I think there's something like Star
Trek where we are so nerdy about it and
the the people do I mean for God's sake
they released a technical manual at the
Enterprise you know things like that
loads of these things if you're gonna
sort of push that and you know that
we're nerdy about it then you've kind of
got to make an effort to stick to it
um but there are certain things you
shouldn't
[ __ ] with and that's the problem with
that I think with JJ Abrams he just went
right I want to do a new thing it's a
prequel so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to do this whole time rewind
me think and then I can do whatever I
want and that's fine I I don't I I love
the those those movies I think they're
actually really good movies I just don't
think they're really Star Trek
I think they're um their JJ Abrams Star
Trek and that's fine
[Music]
um
they can't do that sort of thing too
often
but there's a big argument about them
maybe doing it with Stargate at the
moment and like going well that's how we
can restart everything just let's do
like a JJ Abrams and I'm like please God
don't kill me now
um
but there's
but there are certain things you can't
change and I think with the Klingons
when they change them for like the third
time in Discovery because they they
mirrored the JJ Abrams Klingons I just
thought that wasn't necessary you could
have
you could have left that and they but
they even they made them even worse
because they made them
creepy
and so they changed what the Klingon was
and that did that that was crossing the
line for me that was just like this is
this isn't right this is this has gone
too far
I actually this is one of the ones that
obviously gets gets so much discussion
and I I do not love the season one
Klingons I have made no secret of that
nor am I about to make a secret of that
now uh I I appreciate it that the season
two Klingons you know the simplest thing
of shorten the skulls a little bit and
bring the hair back I think went to good
ways to make to making you think but um
I I'm laughing because I like what they
did in Picard with the romulans I was
like he's got The Ridges from the north
[Music]
lower decks does a really good gag
there's one episode and I think every
Klingon appears in it every variation of
Klingon I like they're all I know it's
like I'm fine with that it's it's when
you get like
this is all a Klingon will ever be it's
like well no we know they won't be
um and obviously so Enterprise does its
thing where it explains the smooth
foreheads away
um and there's and there's an argument
for should they have done that should
they have left it at the trials and
tribulations it's a long story and we
don't talk about it you know maybe that
would be enough
um the one thing I appreciate I I am no
fan of Star Trek Into Darkness I've I've
but there's one thing I appreciate it's
the fact that JJ Abrams gave us the
bling odds
yeah um I just like you know kind of
like oh whatever that's about it I just
love them I think I thought pierced them
all because they would
you kind of think they would do that I
mean if there was ever anyone was going
to be decked in you know kind of the
Predator it would be variations of the
Klingons I think as well I think it does
make sense yeah well I think what we
probably love the most is the the next
gen DS9 Voyager Klingons I mean I I
think they they pretty much I I think
you've gotta you've got a pretty perfect
thing there and even I like how DS9 even
turns on its head a little bit like you
know the that discussion uh between esri
and Wharf there in the last season where
she talks about this Klingon Empire has
gone stale and it had it really had at
that stage uh because remember this is
an Empire I said they're annexing
planets you know these are not
necessarily the good guys
that they come across as you know kind
of like I mean they talk about back in
you know we're going back to the
original series now but Aaron of Mercy
core thinks he's had 300 organians
executed because they wouldn't say yes
to something I mean it's like this is
core the harmaster who rocks up again in
DS9 like you know hey of course do you
remember that time you had 300 organians
seemingly put to death oh yeah yeah good
times right
um mistakes for me
decisions were high yeah
and so I think
but at the the aesthetic the the sh is
it now I love the Klingon ships of again
like that I have right here
there we go like that I didn't even ask
them you know I love that uh so I did
struggle quite a bit with the discovery
ships in season one I quite letter
ancient ships from Discovery season one
though I thought were great I thought
they looked amazing
on ships all looked like [ __ ] I wanted
to use part of my French I thought they
were all horrible and the whole
um cloaking device thing and I just I
just hated it but um
yeah but I know I've got to let things
out I like this it's in a Screen Rant
videos it's the Canadian fellows again
names escaped me and he he's does you
know did the pitch meetings and he says
Ryan George yeah Ryan George thinking
yeah um what's happened because the
story needs to happen and I'm like
sometimes the story just needs to happen
sometimes she's just gonna go yeah okay
we've got this technology
um it does something completely
different to what we told you to do
before because the story needs to happen
it's a calm down
um but I do think there is there is a
line they shouldn't cross I think disco
is danced over that line a little bit
for sure I think yeah disco is the one
that's probably taking the most
Liberties and I to be honest I'm not
really sure where I come down on sort of
thing because there's been bits I've
really enjoyed uh there's my best I
really haven't enjoyed
um and I think you you've put it really
well that like the story needs to happen
and so
you know there there are things which
will annoy people uh myself included uh
I there was
what I remember there was one episode of
season one and I was texting my body
during it and something happened and I I
texted a a very blue word
and I was I was I was I was quite
unhappy uh yeah and then he got back and
he was like
ah look
um you know I can either get hung up on
on this or that
or I can kind of move up not to say
people don't have a right to be upset of
course they do because I think what one
thing particularly about trekkies and I
know this is true of so many fandoms is
that we care we really really get
annoyed did we yeah ignored and stop
watching if we didn't exactly you know
and and discourse is good I like my my
point earlier on about don't go for the
filmmakers like if you go for the
filmmakers I'm sorry you're an idiot but
don't stop having discussions by all
means talk because there's people saying
I loved this episode of next gen I hated
this episode of next gen that's fine
those kind of discussions let's let's
have those kind of talks but it's when
you get the you know doing all you're
getting is vitriol then there's no point
because then that's not a discussion
that someone wants to tell you you're
wrong and then there's no point having
that discussion and lots of people like
like say you have a reasonably
successful YouTube channel and I have
you know a very successful year so we
get comments from people now all they
want to do is tell you that you're wrong
about this and you're right about that
and that and and people get very
energetic about that
um but yeah you know but yeah I'm trying
to play with you um when I saw the
attack Ontario metallic side just
thought it was just silly is it what I
mean okay I don't like the ship but I I
don't like the drive section of the
Titan I think it's awful and the whole
the deflector looks stupid but I'm not
gonna blame him for it
not personally anyway I'm like well you
should be hung drawing and quartered
because you've ruined my show I'm like
it's it's a show
and I'm sure this has been said to you
and you've said to people so like you
kind of want to say like
you know nobody's making you watch this
right yeah no no one's like you're kind
of like you know if you don't watch this
the poppy gets it you know the that's
that that's that's not happening and I
mean one of the lovely things is I mean
right here we're talking about Picard
answering sure what's and Discovery and
you know and Prodigy and Lord it if you
don't like one watch another one there I
I genuinely think that at the moment we
have so much Star Trek that there is
something for everyone
um which is which I I think is great do
you think there's a risk of Star Trek
fatigue again I think we've maybe got
too much Star Trek at the moment too
much no but is there a risk yes there is
um these things go in Ebbs and flows
they always do sci-fi feels like it
feels like it's coming out of a really
popular phase to me it does feel like
it's maybe fantasy and stuff is
if you look at the shows that are coming
over the next couple of years it seems
to be fantasy so it's very popular you
know if you look like Warhammer and God
of War and these sorts of these sort of
TV series and the projects I don't see
a lot of like so but I think the last 10
years though is we've had so much sci-fi
it's been great it's it I don't think
we've had this much sci-fi since
TNG DS9 and Voyager are on Battlestar
Galactica and yeah Stargate was on sort
of thing and then we had like a 10-year
lull with like there wasn't a lot
and you had so many like I mean there
are I suppose last kept the candle
burning for a for for a while
um I like it I suppose lost very much is
sci-fi and then but it was a bit
I don't think anyone's ever said lost
was a bit more grounded it wasn't but
you know what I mean like it was kind of
there was you weren't on a spaceship but
a lot more realistic yes but it was
honest yeah yeah exactly yes it was
probably the most realistic depiction of
uh I've I still don't know what that is
whatever the [ __ ] that was yeah
I don't think the filmmakers did either
um
um and I'm going to see who's like
Fringe and things like that as well
which I thought were great but they
would never like Star Trek you know
there's like that it would actually like
people were talking about it a lot and
it was like you know some of the most
popular stuff on TV and then I'll go to
Lord of the Rings movies
um and things like that but I'm fantasy
but I think I think these things go in
Ebbs and flows
um and it seems to be we seems to be
going into it everything's like um
I used to love the wrestling watching
WWE and that cell goes in episode it'd
be really popular for a bit and then
it's like nobody watches it and it
really does do that
is the
sort of the animated stuff at the moment
Prodigy and lower decks
sort of the best of it
for me I actually think it's that's the
stuff I really enjoy and the live action
stuff maybe not as much
I eat uh my short answer is yes
um like there we go if anyone's
wondering there you go there's my short
answer to that yeah I know it's not as
simple as that though
exactly it because I mean like this this
is such a part of everything's got its
strengths everything's also got its
weaknesses I I not to be too much of a
politician in answering this
um lower decks is the one I enjoy the
most
I will say that every single week I
laugh whether it's just once or whether
it's all the way through I always laugh
during an episode of lower decks okay
Prodigy I've been the most impressed by
um because it's a kids show but it
doesn't but it doesn't act like it
that's it and that and you're you're so
right you're so I'm like obviously yes
it's Nickelodeon and it's you know it's
it's kid friendly
but in the true Spirit of Star Trek if
there is such a thing which there is but
anyway it it doesn't Pander it doesn't
speak down now it don't I mean there are
certainly episodes where it's a bit like
I I I've you know I've been I've been
lucky enough to to chat to the writers
about this one I struggled with Dal in
the first few episodes I really did and
he went on an arc so that's what you get
for sticking with the season I think
that it was it was a Paramount decision
it wasn't a prodigy decision to split
the season into uh season two will be 20
all the way through it's big gap isn't
awesome yeah they were they were told do
10 episode arcs yeah um but which I
think and that there will still be a 10
and a 10 in season two but it's going to
air as far as I know from episode 20. so
there was a big problem we'd almost
forgotten about it but by the time it
sort of came around again it was um
between the two that was it that was
actually that was a problem this is
something so YouTuber to YouTuber I know
you'll understand this so when the first
block of episodes were airing and I I
have I have harsh things to say about
Paramount particularly when it came to
um Prodigy because over here there was
sodol marketing for it you know what
kind of nothing at all you know kind of
like yeah Nickelodeon wasn't pushing us
Paramount wasn't pushing it I mean we
live the world lives online push it
online you know do social media accounts
do YouTube you know as as they did for
discover Discovery In fairness for you
couldn't see for Discovery ads for a
long time do you know what I mean like
it was like they they nailed that in
terms of marketing and so much energy
went into that regret I think the
discovery numbers have been quite
consistent work of course they have been
good otherwise we wouldn't have got the
card we wouldn't have got this
and and then so we were doing uh reviews
or reviews and I just now I'm not saying
we do crazy numbers but we you know we
do enough that we have to be there is as
we've discussed there is a cost to
making these videos uh you know you I
mean if you're losing money every week
unfortunately you can't make the videos
nothing else I mean and that's it
because you know and there is there is
boring algorithm reasons the video
doesn't do well the channel doesn't get
pushed it I say it's boring because
we've spent how long looking at these
algorithms going why won't you work in
our favor and so we got to do it halfway
through the first block of episodes for
prodigy
and compared to all of the other series
that the views were like you know kind
of like but it's Star Trek sure it's got
the name Star Trek on it people are
going to watch it people didn't know it
was on and for a good while people
couldn't watch it because it was only on
Pluto TV and then you know the world has
moved away from
if you don't watch it at eight o'clock
on a Friday you can't see it and that's
it was it was because it wasn't on TV on
demand no it's not that we've moved away
from appointment television Game of
Thrones proof that but um so it was kind
of even now go straight on streaming I
mean even in the UK though it's it's on
at eight o'clock on Monday and then it
immediately goes on to yeah the
streaming so people can watch it when
they want
um
I had that problem with Star Trek
Discovery season three I think because
it went on to Pluto so I could watch it
here but I'm like am I gonna watch on a
Tuesday or a Thursday night you won't
tell me when I'm going to watch Star
Trek so I had to get I had to wait for
power plus but I did and actually it's
funny because you're so right
that's what killed the original series
like and in the end that's what killed
it it was they put on the 10 o'clock
slot on a Friday night
their target audience wasn't watching
this at 10 o'clock on a Friday night you
know in 1969 probably their target
audience was in the pub at 10 o'clock on
a Friday night you know
um and and that is but we had to stop
doing our review episodes unfortunate
and we we were it was it killed us to do
it because if there's what that's what
we do track culture we do our upstairs
we love it it is great you know kind of
and even if the episode is you know
let's say uh a Bad episode and the Downs
outnumber the UPS we still cover because
the audience there the audience was not
there for the first block of episodes
now thankfully that did turn around for
the second block because Word of Mouth
spread
because it wasn't viral marketing it was
Word of Mouth
it was like 100 really good you should
watch it I remember getting some uh some
very fair questions going like oh you
know you know would you consider still
doing this and like listen my personal
Instagram my Twitter whatever 100 I will
tell you no problem I will review this
um you know of course it's it's about it
sounds very boring and cut and dried
it's like if we can't afford to make the
video based on the return I can't do the
ups and downs for it I am I am
legitimately sorry I got one or two not
many but one or two people oh you're
only in this for the money yes I'm
living in my Mansion here uh you know
where where I own my own small island
based off the uh the income where I live
everything's free so no I don't have to
worry about brilliant yeah yeah
I just I just steal I need
um the thing I liked about Prodigy
though is that it's a kids show
but and it's aimed I was on Nickelodeon
it's done in partnership with
Nickelodeon who's on Nickelodeon I think
the first few episodes in America are on
Paramount but then they immediately
switched to Nickelodeon if I'm right
um so it was aimed at
an audience of people that didn't exist
when Janeway was on the TV
but Janeway is the it's one of the most
interesting characters in it
um I hate the [ __ ] by the way I hate the
protostar I hate it I'm gonna sorry it's
ugly it's stupid it's too tall
um
but I love the show I adore it but it's
like lower decks for me like low decks I
felt like initially was just a love
letter to the Next Generation and that's
why I loved it it was it was so
different
and they really allowed themselves to be
a bit silly and a bit you know and it
was you know it's again it's an animated
thing but it was still Star Trek and
even though it was sort of poking fun in
places and it was having a laugh but it
was it was just a love letter to the
Next Generation to me so I'm watching it
just like that McMahon guys just did
such a
just a fantastic job and um and yeah
that show needs to run forever as far as
far as I'm concerned I mean I think as
as long as there's other attractive
parody you've got material for a lower
decks now nobody obviously has
historians but it doesn't
I mean you know what's been the highest
stake Story So Far Jimmy and that's
that's the gas that's the fun bit of it
um whereas Prodigy now Prodigy has
Stakes and that's which which I really
really like lower decks I mean
I remember the first the very very very
first promotional image of the Cerritos
I remember okay well they're clearly
going with the TNG aesthetic at the time
I'm not sure I like the ship of course
mine they're made of that long yeah
um and then that opening scene and it's
space Dock and you're just like
oh I think I'm going to like this show
yeah and I did like this show very very
very much so uh and then like towards
the end of the second season we're like
Sovereign class Starships started
turning up and things like this and they
did a really nice job with that as well
um I just I loved it the whole double
episode at the end of the last season I
just thought was fantastic it was just
so clever and and it but it was it
that's why I love it it's proper Star
Trek which is like this is the show I
loved I watched discovering sometimes
I'm thinking yeah I recognize bits and
you know I I know what they're talking
about now they reference things for me
every so often but it doesn't feel like
Star Trek
Prodigy and lower decks and strange new
rules to be fair I think as well it
feels like Star Trek
with Jason Williams is a bloody prequel
again I hate prequels but I I think when
because I'm not necessarily disagreeing
with you either I I think when you put a
prequel disagree with me though Sean
it's okay I give you permission so this
is why you're wrong but like it's when
you put the point of title on anything
you've
you've set yourself a challenge you know
what I mean you've done like okay you
know you will have people like us being
like yeah but in this day he wasn't
there because this was happening
um and
you know like which is I mean I I like
for me Discovery discovery's best season
for me is probably season two
um I think they got the balance right
now the arrival of the Enterprise and
Pike helped a lot and it's not just that
oh Pike is so much better than all the
other characters but Blake helped the
characters I think have something a
little bit to focus around I think
there's a there's a there's a lot of
what what are we doing this week uh even
in a serialized show as we went into
season three and uh do when you can do
watch season four I won't lie to you
there is bits where it drags
um but I I did a review on
was it the finale it was either the
second last or the last episode of
Discovery season four and
it was one of the most purely Star Trek
episodes that has been released since
the Next Generation okay
um
I will get around to it at some point I
just need to get Paramount back and I'll
watch it and having a bit of time
unfortunately because one of the joys of
YouTube I'm having a YouTube channel
because it takes up a freaking lifetime
I have a Sci-Fi channel I never have
time to watch any sci-fi no it's um it's
a catch-22 but um but now I will get
around to it at some point
because of hopefully Stargate before I
let you go because I'm taking up most of
your Saturday
um but stargate's hopefully going to be
coming back and we we've become pretty
much a Stargate channel on here because
I I happen to have a few people I can
speak to and I find out bits of
information and stuff so um we talked
and it's my favorite show I was always
attractive always and then Stargate it's
Trek end Stargate and I just fell in
love it's like it's like the second wife
you know it's it's Target for me
um
you talking about how Star Trek how
discovering things to this I think one
of the things they have to do when they
have a new show like this is they you
have to do something a bit different
because if you don't and I even think
that would Deep Space Nine Voyager
people go well why isn't this like Star
Trek next Generation it's just because
it's got to be a little bit different
this goes got to be a little bit
different or people just go well this
isn't the same why yeah particularly
when there's a big gap of like you know
what was it between Voyager engine and
disco starting 12 years or something
ended 2001. it was 16 years 16 years
yeah so I mean that's a good thing we're
pushing that I think it's 12 years for
Stargate at the moment since it's been
on the screens yeah SGU I think that's
right something like I kept seeing the
videos it's 16 years and somebody keeps
I've had the guy coming you've said it
again
well he is and I'm like yes Star Trek's
was 16 years I don't know I got that
stuck in mid
um
anyway
but what do you think if I if you were
if you were involved in in creating a
franchise for Stargate it was a fantasy
job I think if you've got Fox YouTube
I'm not doing it anymore I'm gonna go
and work on something
um is there lessons you would take from
how they did Star Trek
yeah if the lessons you think you could
take into a franchise like Stargate
which are all parallels between the two
oh the franchises I think I think big
time I think
so I I think so I like as you know I'm a
big Stargate fan as well and again
Stargate was one of the better series
for handling standalones in the middle
of an arc
and I think don't lose that because I
think that that really really because it
worked on sg1 and it worked on Atlantis
uh Universe I think
um I love it battle gate Galactica
um and I really like Universe don't get
me wrong and they and they were right to
do something different as as you've just
said they had because if you had
another one you can't be like already
going to just go to a different galaxy
and then do the same story again which
it will be fine but then the challenge
is on you to make those same stories new
and I think with the universe they do
that and I do get why people struggled
with it a little bit
and I think that's that's something to
bear in mind if
I don't want to reboot
I I will say we had the reboot it's
called sg1
yeah you know
um
and
you know I would like to uh
I don't I don't think you can't go dark
with us
um you know you could have
because what's going on 12 years have
gone by right yeah
I don't I don't I have no interest in
going into the politics of it but what I
will say is that sg1 was an incredible
show for giving a positive view on
American militarism without beating you
over the head with the American flag
you know there was no kind of like and
we this is why America is the best they
didn't do that and yet they still
managed to paint soldiers as humans
which I think was excellent and it was
very very very important particularly in
the early 2000s
um now neither of us are Americans and
so as Outsiders looking in the last few
years I've been okay so without
propaganda bring the humanity through
that's what Stargate did very very good
point it was the human I mean they even
did poke fun at the image of the
American Military and government at
times in Stargate I remember one episode
was O'Neill wanted to go back to a um
they captured tilk I think so they want
you want to go back to the planet and by
force and rescue him and Hammond was
sort of like well you can't do we can't
just go and interfere with other
people's beliefs and nobody know what
I'm saying since when isn't that what we
do
yeah not anymore no no no we have to
actually be moral now and but that was
kind of you know that that sort of thing
happened but I always love Stargate
because it was so grounded and like it
was always thinking it could be
happening and I think it'll be a shame
if they move away from that but Brad
Wright was going to he was going to say
they're at the Stargate now is known
everybody knows about it so that
basically and I did a video I think a
while ago saying I don't want Star Trek
I want Stargate and they are different
there are parallels in the franchises
and the way how popular they were and
you know a big gap between series and
um but
they are different as well and I think
that'll be a shame but Mike yeah My
worry is that they'll I don't think the
new Star Trek is a is a solely
continuation I I called it like um like
a hybrid reboot in that they picked and
choose what was Canon and they've
ignored bits and they've changed where
they've needed to and I think a lot of
the time you've got to because the whole
the store has got to happen thing and
we're a different generation now as well
and we've moved on something
I just don't want Stargate to do that
but I suspect they will I think I think
they'll have to
if nothing else it'll be a streaming
series instead of a network series and I
think there are differences
in the format and the way a TV shows put
together
just because of that that I think will
force changes but I think it'll be a
shame I I think I think you're right it
would be very interesting to see what
story it looks like streaming yeah
um I am I right saying if it is it's
going to be Amazon uh they bought I
think they own sorry
must still be producing it but it'll be
from what I've been telling him that
Amazon have just got in a completely
absorbed MGM now so yeah it's Amazon
um I would
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm Gonna Keep I'm
gonna keep an open mind you know um I
really really really
would love a sequel series
um it doesn't necessarily need to be
Stargate sg12
um but I do I I I think it would be
you have all the ingredients there
so use them and it's a massive universe
as well they can do Standalone things
they can do I think like they can with
Star Trek which I wish they kind of
would would Star Trek a bit more is it
it's a big universe think about talking
about this with Star Wars and the TV
series let's not do another series on
Tatooine let's do go somewhere else and
do some it's it's quite a big universe
and they did that and what could they do
with Andor to be honest I thought it was
great
um but Star Wars is the same you can do
Standalone things because it's a big
universe and you count on Star Trek and
I wish they would a bit more which is
why I was a bit frustrated with
them doing strange new worlds in a way
because I'm just thinking
just don't just just do something
up to date where we are now in the
timeline
with some of these characters because
just don't put on the interest the
series of enterprise
I I always thought that was brilliant
idea I hate prequels I hate them I think
they're dangerous they annoy me I think
they ruin the storyline
but with disco with Enterprise I can
completely see what they were doing so
I'm like we get to see how the
Federation came to be yeah
that's a brilliant idea and but then
that's why the show sort of like Nars me
so much because they then didn't do it
they go let's have a time why don't have
a time War instead like no I remember
the Federation become I was like that's
what we want to see
um oh it is like you know give get give
us a get give us a show
set between the birth of the Federation
and even Strange New World you know I
would love to see that you know see how
how the NX Class goes to be the
Constitution class how you know that you
know let's bring what they had a
discovery into it show us the shenzhou
show us these kind of things you know
um
but uh but yeah you never know you never
know that that next show that we know is
coming
um
it could be anywhere in the time frame
exactly yeah you know anywhere up to the
32nd Century you know like no it could
be anywhere oh they could oh they could
have a prequel they'd have been
dinosaurs or something for a winner
um just to find a last question and I am
really honestly Gonna Let You Go because
an hour and a half
wow
um but this is such a brilliant topic to
talk about in you yeah and thank you so
much again for coming up because you've
been absolutely amazing as I knew you
would be
um but what I I was worried that there
was a risk with um strange new worlds
that they would wander into basically
remaking the original series and and
that just reimagining it basically what
sort of a risk do you think that is of
coming into next not necessarily the
next series the situation was but the
year after and uh
I think they they would they will have a
challenge so
um quality of Mercy is a reimagining of
balance of Terror mm-hmm and I think
they did it well I think they did it
well I think they they need to bear in
mind the fine line between homage and
remake because
I'm by by no means was the original
series perfect
um like actually on good Lord re-watch
the original series it is not perfect
but um
I you know I I do like
the idea of revisiting or setting things
up you know um there was I know there
was plans for season five of Enterprise
that would have seen them uh visit
Stratos
and the cloud minders planet that would
set up then for you know 100 years later
Kirk would arrive
that stuff I'm cool with
you know
um like I I like that kind of stuff you
know things that we haven't seen since
the original series
um
and there was one why do you think they
don't do that as much as you think it's
supposed to be the only tricky is to get
it
yes I know like there's a lot of there's
a lot of voice gags in Enterprise
um like I think it was that episode
Twilight uh where it's future Archer has
no memory and you know all of the rest
of humanity they're gonna be fine
because they're on the way to set el for
five
oh no and there was another one I I it
sounds terrible now that I can't
remember the name of the race but there
was one there were like baddies in
Enterprise and they were really
frustrating and they were meant to annoy
you but don't worry because that's the
star system The Nomad probe blows up in
the original series episode The
Changeling it's like when they get
theirs don't worry
um and like things like that yeah I I
think are cool at least just for us when
you go into like let's say I didn't love
Harry mod in Discovery I thought that I
thought they went a bit too they went a
bit over the line of what is homage and
what is
um I'm not like by no means am I a Harry
mud Lover from the original series yes
absolutely recast I have no problem with
recasting that's a whole lot of
discussion we can have but I don't have
a problem I have no problem we mentioned
the ball Queens earlier they kind agree
Caster Queen because she's kind of
supposed to be the same yeah being or
something interesting but they did it so
well it's like
great
um that was a it's a good um
text so a friend of mine had a good a
good job it's like right yeah if you go
into one of those vitriolic chat rooms
right like one of the real ones where
it's like you know there is only there's
only one real Star Trek it's the cage
you know like where you go into one of
those rooms right and the best way to
Royal the room I was like okay guys
let's talk who was the best Spock
Quinto or Peck
yeah
run away run get out of that room you're
not safe
um that was a really long answer to that
um I think they do need to be aware
don't remake an episode reimagine is
fine don't do it every season I liked
quality of Mercy but let's yeah yeah
don't don't read that's one is great you
know
um but like there's so much else for
example
um
we've got to meet the Klingons as well
hey that's that's good oh well and it
does not go well at all no
um something yeah the reason all that I
think isn't there a Romulan War at some
point in that time frame as well just
before it's the original series or was
that through oh I get a mixed up in my
head now as well there there because
there's a few differences
um but yeah I think there's time frame
there's supposed to be about five years
before the Original Series starts I
think there is a there is a lump of time
still isn't there but
we'll have to oh there is yeah yeah
there is so because was the cage is
22.54 yeah um where no man has gone
before is 22.64 and
um stranger worlds is yeah as you said
it's roughly in fact it's 22.59 we did a
we did we did a check yeah so we got
five or six years
um I know I know that's because that's
right with when Kirk was on the Farragut
and it was just after the everything
that happened on the fire so all the
time frames match you up and they've got
a few years until Pike is
Mel has to sit down a lot yeah oh yeah
he gets tired likes bless him
Sean thank you so much for coming on the
channel it's been absolutely phenomenal
um I love geeking out like this
for a while so it's um like I said I
talk about Stargate so freaking much at
the moment because I love it and we want
the show to come back so I keep going
banging my drum about it but it's nice
to talk about a bit of Trek and um and
your knowledge you didn't do too well on
the quiz but then you basically then
spent an hour and a half naming episodes
so I think you you um
you came through all right in the end so
my job's writing on this like you know
kind of like you know Monday morning
Sean can we have a talk with you please
oh God you've been watching internet
bug Eric but um honestly thank you so so
much and everybody's been in the
comments I'm sorry I've been so talking
to Sean I've not read any of them
um but thank you for interacting and um
it's been absolutely brilliant but thank
you very very much I have an ending bit
for this which I can never find
that's great I'll just send it bye-bye
goodbye everyone thank you so much I'm
just wondering when I was a kid right I
don't know again there's no Chucky I
used to do that oh God yeah practice
yeah
without closing your thumb is that where
is it I can't do it as well as I used to
be able to do yeah that's it
yeah that actually yeah God that looks a
bit like that's good that's someone's
just screenshotted that
thank you okay hopefully we'll see you
again oh thank you
just got away